[Music]
hey guys its price and bon Qui Qui is
here welcome bank week we thank you now
you are you're very fast of lead rest
today thank you thank you very much I
got McCrimmon lights right here you know
I mean I got my ugly sweater
even though spirits not ugly but you
know for sale on your website that's
right is this lie and we're here to talk
about you have a Christmas EP out yes I
do
why do a Christmas EP I mean listen
everybody is used to they classic creamy
songs that they sing all the time you
know I mean like how many how many years
we've been singing deck the halls oh my
god we get it's like the halls okay so I
wanted to write a song that's more
relevant to today you know me because
like when you go criminal types you
almost got into already just yesterday
of the day some do try to get my parking
spot and I was like ooh back up homie
you know I mean so I want to write a
song that was like about these we go to
through today that's not about decking
the hose we have a little bit of deck
the hose to listen to will play that now
for your enjoyment I get my water one um
oh but you take care of me justice
message for all my single babies and got
a min so I don't want you going crazy if
you ain't gonna is
I guess I'm pretty in rocket sorry
closely a Christmas song for 2016
that's what it is it really is now the
whole album is called merry hood miss
and also features jingle bells sleigh
and I'm joy to the world that's right
so I'm joy to the world that's basically
my song telling everybody you welcome
for the gift of me you know them because
I'll be making people laugh making
people smile I don't know be say thank
you sorry let you know what you welcome
you don't gotta tell me nothing you
welcome you don't have to say thank you
but she'll tell you you're welcome
alright well if you have questions for
bon Qui Qui put them in the comments
below
I'll get them here I'll ask them for you
we're so technologically advanced phone
on the table and everyone okay go ahead
add me a question everybody uh now
you're also touring and performing along
with this party we'll see you okay so I
had already done two tours okay and so
we did the first tour cuz I was I first
came out my album um gold-plated dreams
and we did that one a couple years ago
with Warner Music and I was like what am
I going to her then and it's so out I
was ah my god people came to my show it
sold out so I did it again a second time
it sold out again you don't me laugh but
okay I guess I'll do it one more game so
now we're going a third time this spring
we're going in April in May we're gonna
go to different cities this time and
we're gonna do it one last time for
everybody one last time that's right
last chance to see her live last chance
then the gold plated Dreams tour is a
good one too you don't want to me you
don't want to miss it wanna miss cuz
I'll be doing my hair single imma cut
you do that one a modern-day classic
that's right I do by that one's just
that song is for like you know anytime
you meet somebody they say something so
stupid or so dumb then I you don't even
have the energy to entertain a response
to them that you just say bye that's it
just oh okay uh-huh bye and I get an
anthem for dealing with idiots all right
lots of comments coming in Robert says
slay talent wants to know where'd you
get your nails did oh my girl Tina
hooked me uh
inna gold at cutie cow nails that's who
she is
each one is different yes they all have
their own personality like me Christina
says she wants to know where she can get
your sweater it's on your website right
yes with this one you could get this one
I'm a home girl website Angela calm she
hook you up right here but this mean
that's gone quickly and this is slay
right here can see you sly night and
it's Angela with a J yes a n je lah calm
Nina says you de bomb Kimmy says what
should I get my boo for Christmas hmm
how long has he been your boo that's a
real question is a long term okay so
long term boo this way I want you to do
you're gonna get two gifts okay you
gonna get level a gift and then level B
gift you wait and see what he give you
okay be like oh my god this is just a
little baby t-shirt and it's not even
that cute never be that's what you get
you get him no socks that you got him
you know I'm saying but if he come out
give you guys some Tiffany's or some
amazing then that's when you give them
little a boom Jordans there you go oh I
like it
well we are only a few days away from
Christmas I can't believe it what are
your last-minute gift ideas just general
last-minute gift ideas last-minute gift
ideas I mean okay always there's a gift
card for every single store you ever
heard of even if it's not a store they
got a gift card for it you know I mean I
just went to the grocery store the other
day they got a gift card for PlayStation
like that's not a store no yeah that's
like you should go online put your gift
card and rent a game or something I
don't know how to work um so I mean
there's always gift cards um you could
give somebody if you good at arts and
crafts if you a good crafty person maybe
make something I'm not that good at
crafts ease I mean I do bedazzle my own
clothing sometimes so if you could be
dads or something I think maybe they
would like that
I like that add a personal touch Jerry
wants to know if you will marry him oh
my god Jerry you can submit your
headshot and resume and I will consider
uh uh Robert wants to know when we will
get a bon Qui Qui movie
oh my god could you imagine about what
what's the ugly story be I mean I don't
know if it would be like a biopic on me
like how I came up you know to where I
am today or maybe I should be an actress
and play something else I maybe I'll be
like an action movie and then I could
just like pull out a gun and shoot the
bad guy or something oh yeah oh I'd want
to see that one I'd want to see that one
uh Valerie wants to know what's the
worst Christmas gift you've ever
received and it made you say rude okay
Valerie listen if you have seen my video
deck the hostess what happened one time
this do heed this why I say wait and see
what he get you first this why say that
okay he got me some red bottoms
what girl you know don't want some red
bottoms right so I got me some red
bottoms like oh my god he loved me so
much
girl why dump peeled the red off it
wasn't even legit I just peeled it right
off
you can see in my deck the whole video
Oh got it
youtube.com and search deck the hoes
you'll find it right
ah Meghan says yes to a movie Brett says
girl what is in your cup you did bring
your own cup oh this right here does a
little a fancy basic up right here it's
a secret you ain't allowed to know this
I try and get rested over here at et you
know saying no no police involved here
Melissa wants to know what is your
favorite lipstick oh my favorite Liz
your makeup is looking flawless today
thank you so much
ah let me see I just started using this
one from mac cosmetics it's their
long-wear where you put it on it stays
on until like Thursday you know I mean
like that's the one I like when it when
it stays on for a long time almost like
a tattoo yeah a little bit like that oh
you know what my grandma she tattoo on
her lipstick and her eyeliner oh wow
that's called OG chola right there
that's my grandma's you know she done
tattooed it all on and brynn says you
are my spirit animal hey breathe thank
you so much all right now I was when I
have you would treat us to a bon Qui Qui
Christmas treat and do a little live
reading of twas the night before
Christmas for us
9:00 before Christmas okay see this one
a new story for me because we tell a
different story in the hood where I grow
up we tell a different one it's the time
about when Santa got robbed for his leg
and they jacked him but don't worry good
bum quickly save the day in that story
okay
ready everybody twas the night before
Christmas when all through the house not
a creature was stirring not even a
little mouse coming up in there he ain't
even invited no ok ok the stockings were
hung by the chimney with care they
didn't just do it like they didn't care
about it they did it with care in hopes
that Saint Nicholas soon would be there
is this a Nicholas they're not saying
Nichols oh maybe we might I don't know
typos in this book Clement more you
better get it right Nicholas please
thank you I watched with my movies okay
the children were nestled all snug in
they bed while visions of sugarplums
danced in the head do you know what a
sugarplum me no idea no person in the
whole entire world know what sugarplum
is this a made-up dessert okay in mama
in her kerchief in her kerchief just
what's up her chips wearing a napkin on
her head and mamma in her kerchief and I
in my cap had just settled down for a
long winters nap okay about to hibernate
ha ha ha humans hibernating ok there's a
long page just too long we just yeah
there we go there we go he spoke not a
word but went straight to his work work
work work work work and he feel all the
stockings they turn with a jerk
I'd say they got a jerk in there look at
grk I know that I meant want to do it
before the one huh ok let me see
look II don't have gang signs
a woman is standing from he'd be like I
look at him game sound right here
Santa Claus what you promised Annie hey
wait you from sandy doesn't Horsa you
got us a North Pole son look ok for
next page okay in a way they all flew
like the down on the thistle ooh this
okay but I heard him exclaim ere he
drove out of sight okay that'll make no
sense next last one
merry Christmas to all and to all a good
night
travel fonts for bon Qui please reading
of I'm the only one clapping nobody's in
here ah you know I think we just got the
gist of it I think we maybe missed a
couple parts but we got the gist of that
you boring story it has to be updated a
little bit yeah cuz I mean nobody knows
what a sugar plum is what would you
replace the sugar plum we uh dimly Oh
chocolate doughnuts from the gas station
oh yeah that's that's right little taco
six donut one yeah you come on tell me
wouldn't want to grab every time you go
and get some gas please there we go
alright Jeremy wants to know if you'll
ever go back to work at King burger you
know what no no I will not get mo I did
go back recently I don't know if you
watch MADtv the new one I went back
recently and I say hello to Otto staff
there mr.william he don't work there
anymore but now I triangle back their
salary says love you Annie wants to know
if you're single and are you living that
single girl life well yes I am single I
had had my boy dramas I mean the one he
still try to call me up err now and then
but I try to talk to him no more um I
was just dating this one do
but he took what's that term he ghosted
me oh yeah like that's a real thing I
hate I hadn't known that was the things
I had never been close to why you want
to go this huh but then it happened we
was like yeah gum I'll call you on
Thursday guess what happened this boo
didn't call me oh and then that was like
two Thursday's ago so maybe he wasn't
specific
I'm gonna call you Thursday four weeks
from now but I don't know whatever find
out in the future I sure don't want to
know what your favorite Christmas song
is uh my favorite Christmas song a
jingle bells sleigh that's my own song I
love that one
Derrick oh hey oh yeah giggle best-laid
that's my favorite one um then deck the
hose then I'm joy to the world okay yeah
that's my face keep it humble that one's
the third one yes the one that's all
about you and then I do like more I
carry all I want for Christmas
Oh would you ever cover that I think I
would I think I would I can't really hit
the high note that she'd do like if I
practice if I warm up give me some hot
tea with some lemon I might be able to
get up there but I might have to throw a
little out of tune on that one got it
all right Sandra wants to know if you
can do a wrap for us this is putting you
on the spot
oh yeah yeah I mean um well well my song
right now let me see uh
deck the halls which one I want to do
deck the halls day the house who could
la la la la la la la la la
you could wait your turn is my fa la la
la la la la la la
don't you think that I won't cut you
fala Lala la la la la la Merry Christmas
nice to beat you finally Allah la la la
la
yes the Christmas spirit is alive oh
there's the claps I need an earlier
video everybody learned all right well
you can get a bond quickly Christmas EP
everywhere music is sold right now
download it today get it for that car
ride to Grandma's yes sing it why you
around a Christmas tree while you in
your turkey or whatever you eat I don't
know what you eat you know I mean but
when it's Christmas time you won't play
this song show it to everybody you know
why you driving in a parking lot getting
those last-minute grins there's less
many gifts that's what you want to
listen to right there and if you want to
you can pick up the merch over at Angelo
calm
Angelo with a J yes you can pick up this
you can pick my music you could pick up
tickets to see me on tour cuz I'm going
on tour again oh oh you can pick out all
that alright people are loving you wants
you on tour we're gonna wrap this up
now we'll make sure to follow up on
quiqui on all her social media and don't
forget to like ET right here so you
don't miss when we're live with your
favorite stars like bon Qui Qui see you
guys next time in happy holidays
mwah